[Música]
economía en directamente América de
Francia 24 Juan Pablo lucumista con
nosotros en el estudio Juan Pablo buen
día hoy es el último día del foro
económico mundial y en esta sección
vamos a revisar Cuál es el resumen de
las conclusiones que se han recogido
desde el inicio de esta semana Así es
Raúl eso es lo que revisaremos hoy
recordemos que el foro inició Pues esta
semana con los informes de oxfam que
cifraron la desigualdad en ese informe
se reportó que el 1% de la población
acumuló una fortuna adicional de más de
42 billones de dólares más del doble que
el restante 99% y se apoderó de dos
tercios de la riqueza desde 2020 ese
mismo día en el marco del foro se
conoció el panorama del empleo mundial
en el que la oit concluyó que la calidad
de los empleos caerá bastante este año
Así como lo hizo el pronóstico de
crecimiento de empleo que pasó del 1,5%
que se esperaba para este año al 1% el
fondo monetario internacional fue otro
también que dio de crecimiento global
apuntando a un 2,7% en 2023 del 3,7 que
se registró el año pasado nuestra
compañera del equipo económico que está
en davos Suiza habló con Moisés naín
exministro de economía de Venezuela
quien resumió el foro como un escenario
de ansiedad frente al panorama que vive
el mundo actual
la confusión la ansiedad este todo el
mundo sabe que va a pasar algo
importante en la economía o con el
cambio climático o un accidente
Cibernético que están pasando cosas
grandes cambios tectónicos en la
estructura mundial etcétera todo el
mundo sabe que está pasando eso pero
nadie sabe cómo va a terminar eso
afectándolo a él a su empresa a ella su
familia etcétera entonces hay gran
ansiedad porque se espera algo
importante pero no se sabe que es Y esa
ansiedad este está en casi todas las
sesiones de que hay algo pendiente un
tema muy importante Por supuesto es
si va a haber una contracción económica
que es a nivel de recesión o si va a ser
más tenue entonces hay un debate está
están divididos aquí en la conversación
entre quienes creen que va a haber una
profunda recesión prolongada y otros que
dicen que va a ser pasajera Mientras
tanto las tasas de interés que nos
afectan a todos y lo que pagamos por
los automóviles
las casas etcétera se ve afectado por
todo esto no Juan Pablo este foro
económico también tuvo importantes
discusiones ambientales y protestas de
líderes climáticos Raúl el clima fue
indispensable en este foro y pues inició
con críticas a los multimillonarios que
llegaron en sus jets corporativos que
según greenpeace contaminan lo mismo que
350.000 vehículos luego se conoció el
plan Industrial Greenville de la Unión
Europea en el marco de Buscar la
neutralidad de carbono para 2050 y dando
un mensaje también a Asia de tratar de
alejarse Pues de este continente se
desarrolló con la ausencia de los
presidentes de las dos principales
economías hablamos de Joe biden de
Estados Unidos y de China mientras el
jefe de la ONU pues señaló a estos dos
países de desatar una división mundial
esto también mientras dos importantes
figuras se reunieron las dos importantes
figuras de estos dos países se reunieron
en zúrich para tratar de acercar más sus
puntos de vista Entonces que se viene
para latino que es otro de los temas
escuchemos
un año muy difícil un año muy difícil
este de bajo crecimiento de alto
desempleo de inflación y tasas de
interés alta es una lista horrible eso
va a tener consecuencias sobre los que
los informales
y va a ser una época difícil de
transitar Y entonces pronto entraremos
en un torneo de culpas y acusaciones De
quién es el responsable Quién es el
culpable de esta tragedia económica que
va a tener la región por un tiempo hay
un ánimo de pesimismo que no habíamos
visto hace tiempo aquí
Juan Pablo y qué se espera para las
políticas que intentan contener la
inflación Raúl eso precisamente fue lo
que Daniel habló también desde davos con
Julio Velarde el presidente del Banco
Central de Perú dando un panorama de
varios países del continente americano
depende los países Estados Unidos
ciertamente Se espera al menos dos
subidas de 25 puntos básicos Europa
también comenzó Cristina gart estimoforo
se espera Zuleta su interés el caso de
América Latina creo que aeros países ya
ha llegado a su pico en las urna reunión
de Brasil Chile no aumentaron sus tasas
y probablemente ellos sean los primeros
países que comiencen con un descenso su
tasa de interés Una vez que se vea que
la inflación está bajando para bien
no va a ser tan pronto va a ser
inflación sino que se vea que en
inflación efectivamente está en una
descendente Clara y eso va a pasar en
todos los bancos centrales del mundo
creo cifralia los doce mil despidos que
anunció este viernes alfabetink la casa
matriz de Google lo que supone el
recorte del 6% de su fuerza laboral la
compañía dijo que en el pasado amplió su
reforma masiva de manera masiva su
plantilla Y pues lo hizo esperando un
panorama económico distinto al que se
vive hoy y por eso debe ajustarse a una
nueva realidad los despidos de Google se
producen días después de que su rival
Microsoft dijera que despedirá a 10.000
de su planta de empleados Gracias Juan
Pablo como siempre por toda la
información económica más adelante más
economía ahora regresamos ahora
regresamos nosotros nos vamos a davos
Ahí está Daniel lo